hallo mein name ist wie viele leute
schreiben mir mensch viele böse
kommentare ich habe letztens dieses bild
hier auf instagram hochgeladen wo ich am
hauptbahnhof in düsseldorf war das ganze
war ca um sechs uhr morgens deswegen war
ich am schlafen darunter gab es einen
kommentar von maximal 12 13 wie dumm du
einfach im zug eingeschlafen bist du
pussy und dann hat er auch noch
geschrieben drogen sind ungesund conny
warum nimmst du dann welche ich weiß
nicht was ich dazu sagen soll dann gab
es darunter auch den kommentar finger an
denen du scheiße op ich bin also eine
oper und die lehrer hat auch noch
geschrieben das bild es irgendwie voll
doof aber auch cool müssen nicht ein
guter youtuber aber du bist der beste
wollt ihr mich komplett verarschen dann
weiter über weihnachten in österreich
urlaub und habe dort dieses coole
landschaftsbild hoch geladen darunter
kam dann der kommentar von stevie
dukaten bis den austria land der uhren
söhne
ich weiß nicht ich habe ein böse
kommentare schon lange nicht mehr
gemacht weil er halt so viele dumme
kommentare kamen wo man einfach wusste
die leute wollen einfach nur eine folge
reinkommen sind deswegen so blöd aber
sowas ist doch nicht mal witzig das ist
einfach nur dafür kann man doch geblockt
werden oder ich habe dort in österreich
oder außerdem auf das bild die
hochgeladene lag ich im hotel bett und
dachte mir nur so falk wieso liegt kein
schnee und dar und hat mich dann
netterweise eine person auf geklärt
wieso genau dort kein schnee und zwar
hatte user namens es hat geschrieben hey
luca ich hatte vor kurzem das thema
kontinente in australien wird es nicht
schneiden weil das eine reise zone ist
und ich bin zehn und ich kenne dich
schon seit drei jahren
austria ist englisch für österreicher
nicht für australien
aber danke für deine hilfe außerdem wird
der satz anfang groß geschrieben mein
name wird großgeschrieben kurzem wird
groß geschrieben bei thema kannst du
dass er und das haar mal tauschen
kontinente wird groß geschrieben doch
nach kontinent irgendwie drei
leerzeichen gemacht nach es hast du auch
zwei leerzeichen
gemacht heiße wird mit scharfem s
geschrieben zone wird großgeschrieben
und jahren wird großgeschrieben und
satzzeichen hast du übrigens komplett
vergessen
mama ich nehme kein video auf ich mache
gerade deutschunterricht mit meinen
zuschauern
die können das nicht dann war ich bei tv
total weil ich ein buch herausgebracht
hat was er übrigens noch kaufen können
dass ein link in der beschreibung das
ist oder ihr lasst es einfach und als
ich bei tv total war habe ich dieses
bild hier hochgeladen mit stefan raab
und darunter hat sich der cup gefragt
kannst du deutsch spaß
nein nein war kein spaß ich komme schon
durcheinander mit den ganzen spesen
hierher
dann war ich am köln bonner flughafen
irgendwann morgens um halb sieben oder
so und hat dieses tolle bild hochgeladen
das ist einfach wundervoll man das ist
so schön schön schön schön dar und hat
der dari bubi geschrieben am anna anna
amalia mana mana mana mana warum der
jetlag oder irgendwie so hat sich dann
auch so gefragt etwa acht bubi mario
behindert es ich meine danach hat er
geschrieben eine rechtschreibkorrektur
nervt das ist in ordnung das ist nicht
deine fehler wandeln die von mireille
schreib korrektur allerdings hat sich
der darin bubi daran gedacht mein fotos
behindert mein fuß ist ein fuß und kein
echter jetzt schon wieder die ganzen
ich frag mich echt richtig auf was ist
in eurem kopf drin dass wir solche
konversationen führt da schreibt ein
blogger 100 mal am anna und dann
schreibt eine andere behindert und dann
antwortet er wieder fit ist behindert
das kostet euch dann habe ich ja
irgendwann so mehr als ein paar
hochschulen besuchte die möglichkeit mit
einer oculus trifft so selbst gestaltete
spiele irgendwie zu spielen das habe ich
dieses bild hier habe ich da hochgeladen
und darunter wollte ein user namens
moritz unbedingt ins videos verschreibt
er das ist ein bett kommentar kommen ich
jetzt ins video fick dich mein schild du
bist geil
ge
erst 2003 geboren
das heißt er ist zwölf und er hat ein
call of duty bild als profilbild bei
instagram du bist 12 das spiel ist ab 18
ich war bei der eröffnung des saturn
connect stores in köln und dann wurde
eine karikatur von mir gezeichnet und
eine karikatur ist immer so eine
überspitzte darstellung das heißt ein
paar merkmale werden übernommen und mit
fantasie kann man erkennen dass es die
und die person ist allerdings eine
karikatur mal so ein bisschen muss nicht
hübsch sein allerdings dachten sich
meine zuschauer der in bildschirm sieht
besser aus rechte sieht besser aus [ __ ]
euch das hier bin ich als meinen
merchandise wieder verfügbare war
übrigens der ist wieder verfügbar ihr
könnt wieder was bestellen im luca
schottische minister vor
wir hatten sehr oft wartungsarbeiten und
lieferprobleme weil ihr so viel bestellt
habe dann hab ich gesagt ich mein handy
hat gewimmelt sondern habe ich euch ja
gesagt ihr sollt einfach nicht mehr
bestellen und dann habt ihr auch nicht
mehr bestellt und jetzt haben aber alles
wieder da und die können wieder
bestellen also geht auf jeden fall stand
unter diesem bild der kommentar von
knüppel knack luca du siehst mega gut
aus holte eine freundin mann luca macht
doch dann war ich vor zwei wochen bei
der star wars premiere in berlin und
habe dort dieses bild mit kalorien
hochgeladen das ist der bösewicht in dem
neuen star wars film untypisch luca habe
ich natürlich darunter geschrieben
gestern bild mit ihrem mann gemacht das
ist er doch oder so ein bisschen ironie
mäßig ich wusste dass sie das sich halt
neben den ca 2000 kommentaren darunter
die mir verraten haben dass das nicht
ironman ist übrigens danke noch mal
dafür kam auch ein kommentar von klickt
euch all wie sie es aus wie eine anlage
wird auf dem bild solche
nein ich weiß gar nicht ob ihr so was
mögt aber die reaktion von mir sind ja
immer nur so und ich denke mir dann nur
so wie dumm sind manche menschen kommen
wir nun auch schon zum letzten bild was
ich vor einigen tagen hochgeladen habe
als ja noch in österreich war und zwar
dass hier da waren ganz normaler wald
und ich dachte ich jeder könnte normales
foto machen wir in die cola sitzung
nachdenkt aber ich färbe einfach
gedruckt und darunter frag berlin
albania nachhilfe und zwar schreibt er
hey leute könnt ihr mir helfen mich will
youtube werden aber in weißen nicht wie
man ein profilbild in new york gemacht
vielleicht liegt es daran dass es
youtube nicht gibt ich stelle mir gerade
echt vor wie er da auf die website
youtube ist das ein gibt man sich denken
hier gibt's die website überhaupt wenn
man noch die website youtube.com geht
wird man 1000 mal weiter geleitet bis
man angeblich der gewinner eines
smartphone
da kann man sich auf jeden fall kein
profil einrichten lieber die bahnen ja
albaner hieß er noch mal ich möchte mich
hiermit verabschieden von euch ich
wollte mich bedanken für eure soll ich
liebe kochen wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen und schreibt mir die
kommentare ob ihr sowas nochmal haben
wollt und ich mache ich das jetzt
ich geh nach hause